Daniel Jeremiah NFL Network analyst and
he joins us from the combine the NFL
network's coverage live coverage of the
combine starts Thursday at 4:00 Eastern
with quarterbacks wide receivers and
tight ends Daniel thanks for joining us
let me start with that this whole Joe
boroughs situation what is the buzz at
the combine about what they think the
Bengals are going to do and is there an
end game for Jill burrow well I think
there's a lot of chatter Dan about you
know does he try and force his way out
of there and you know I thought there's
two ways you can do that if you chose to
do it and one of which would never work
with my crown of the Bengals and that's
to go John Elway scorched-earth go
public you know and really it kind of
embarrassed the team that would I just
wouldn't work the Bengals would take him
and and not set that type of a precedent
but the other way to do it is kind of
the e live way which is a little more
back-channel so I think if that was
going on I don't know that we would even
know about it
so yeah you know I still think when it's
all said and done he's going to get
picked by the Bengals he's going to show
up and play for the Bengals but if that
was going on behind the scenes I
wouldn't be totally shocked
I think he's keeping it you know maybe
strategically vague on purpose yeah what
do you think yeah I just I just think
again if you come out and go scorched
earth right now it's not going to end
well for you so you know I think you try
and gather as much information as you
can and I've you know I thought it'd be
interesting to see what the Bengals do
and free agency you know if you want to
show that you're committed and you
really do want to win a championship do
something out of your character and go
out there and be a little bit more
aggressive and free agency something
that they just never have really done I
had a source tell me this yesterday a
couple of things we talked about too and
I said if tua didn't have this hip
injury now granted he does have this but
if he didn't would there be serious
debate about who should be the number
one quarterback taken for me I think
you'll get some different answers for me
there is and I would take if to it was
totally healthy I would still take
jobber oh okay so that's my opinion I
know there's there's people on both
sides that argument I really like to a
but to me when you have two players that
played for you know on incredibly
talented teams there
so much of the production you have to
kind of set aside Dan and you have to
dig in and to me you've got to study the
quality opponents they played against
and then you've got to really study the
the the pressure snaps that they played
because there aren't a lot of them I
think with with borough this past year
he had maybe a hundred and eighty of
them I think to a head maybe sixty eight
or right around seventy snaps where he
was under pressure and when you study
the better opponents and you when you
study them when they're under pressure
it's a decided edge for Joe borough and
the way they performed and that to me is
why I ended up with borough over two uh
I also had a source tell me that
somebody's gonna fall in love with
Justin Herbert somebody's gonna go up
and it feels like we're surprised every
year with Mitchell true Biscay or Daniel
Jones that Justin Herbert might be that
quarterback your thoughts I think I
think you'll get a varied opinion on
that one I actually actually think
Jordan Love has more upside than Herbert
so you know I think Herbert in terms of
somebody they can get on the field right
now he's incredibly intelligent he's
played a ton of football he's I think
he's going to be kind of at his ceiling
pretty early on he's a great athlete but
Herbert's not really a playmaker an off
schedule playmaker he's going to execute
at designed into place sheet whereas
Jordan Love has a little bit more moxie
a little more play making ability and a
little more upside but he's just he's
not ready to play right now but I think
Dan when you look at kind of the the
five six and seven you know I think
you're going to see at least two
quarterbacks go in that range you're
gonna have Cincinnati take one then
you're gonna see two more
I believe go in that range I think
Herbert would probably be the favorite
behind to uh to be that third
quarterback but I think it's very real
possibility we have three go in the top
six picks and then another one with
Jordan love once you get down to you
know Raiders Colts Tampa I think you
could see him go in that range also we
make a big deal about quarterbacks hands
why don't we make a big deal about wide
receivers hands it's you know I looked
it up and I every year before the
combine and we'll talk about it on the
air as these workouts are going on but I
like to you know look up how the top
players in the NFL I don't care you know
what everybody in the combine did or
what even NFL starters did but like
receivers I'll take the top ten in terms
of receptions and yard
and then I'll all look up all their
combines numbers and see what you learn
the fascinating thing Dan is the average
for tea time for the top ten receivers
and those statistical categories it's
four five five so if not the four if the
four five but you know what it was a
bunch of them have is stinking huge
hands so it does there is something
there in terms of the hand size those
wide receivers yeah I don't know why
that is one thing to hold a football
it's another thing to catch the football
when it's thrown - that always amazed me
but I saw where mike Mayock was talking
about how it's really tough to try to
figure out how that wide receiver who's
successful in college is gonna be
successful in the pros because it's a
completely different game that's played
there's no press coverage you'd go to a
spot you're usually wide open there I
don't know how much you're reading a
defense there but are you I know you say
this is one of the great wide receiving
drafts in recent memory but how do you
know who's gonna make that transition
well I think first of all that's been a
challenge evaluating you know receivers
making that leap for decades you know
because you're gonna see so much more
press coverage but I think as you know
the more you do it you look at it you
say okay even though he's not seeing
press coverage I can tell by his foot
quickness off the line I can tell by his
strength you got to be press coverage
with your feet of your hands then so
you've got about you to have that foot
quickness to escape or you got to have
the strength upper body wise that's the
power through and get off press so you
kind of have to look at those things and
project what these guys are going to be
able to do the good news is while maybe
you don't see as much press coverage in
some of these college games these kids
have played so much seven-on-seven and
I've run so many routes that I think
there's a lot more route polished to
these guys than we've seen I think it
gets better and better every year and
that's why you're starting to see you
know some of these guys have more of an
impact and you saw it last year with
especially the old miss kids with AJ
Brown and DK Metcalf and Terry Maclaurin
all those guys stepping on the field and
playing pretty well obviously Devo
Samuel would be a poster child Jalen
Hurd's
facing the questions about being a
quarterback or not where do you stand on
Jalen Hertz playing that position I was
encouraged by the fact that I found out
today when they have the meeting and you
can
request for players to play other
positions that none of the 32 teams
requested Jaylin hurts to play another
position which speaks well to the
intelligence of the NFL that they're not
asking this kind of play another
physician be the quarterback it's what
he is there's been some comparisons for
dak Prescott and I think there's
something to that in terms of just the
strength the ability to extend plays I
think dak through with more anticipation
and a little more accurate but this kid
this makes plays man and to me I think
when you get in the second round not
every team is going to have him there
but some team I think is gonna fall in
love with him and say we can kind of
build our offense around somebody like
this talking to Daniel Jeremiah NFL
Network analyst they got the combine
Thursday at 4:00 Eastern with the
quarterbacks wide receivers and the
tight ends when tua gets examined is it
just one doctor who's examining him and
then you get the teams to get the
information from that examination or is
he going to every team I think all those
teams get in there together so you'll
see I think I was talking to Steve Weiss
who's who spent some time around - in
his camp and I think he said it was 10
hours of medical stuff yesterday so it's
it is a long long process you know with
all those teams doctors getting a chance
to look at you and poke and prod you
have to be careful obviously with that
with that injury specifically but you
know the film's I believe yet those same
films obviously get sent out to all the
teams but in terms of the physical
examination each of the teams have an
opportunity their highest graded
quarterback you've ever been around
since you've been doing this and Andrew
Luck Andrew Luck still the highest
graded quarterback that I've done so who
might surprise me that he had a high
grade four well I made it known at the
time I was a big Sam Donald fan so I
have been great on Sand Arnold
are you still I've got a yeah I'm still
hopeful there he's still young
I think he's got all the tools down and
got all the ability they've got to give
him some help and he needs not get mono
that would also be helpful so you get
him that was Daniel that was in would
hope that was in his draft profile
susceptible to
I don't know how you didn't see that or
the judge did I tried that one but Sam
darn old to me if I'm Jill burrows camp
and I look at Sam darn old where I'm not
with a good organization no stability
there and what kind of weapons do I have
like that's where you get into bad
habits if you said that Sam darn 'old
was gonna be playing for the Texans or
the Chiefs
we would look at Sam Darnell differently
that's why we're not quite sure at how
good he is because it feels like the
whole team and the organization you're
not held not sure how good they are yeah
and I you know I'm hopeful with the Jets
I work with Joe Douglas and he's just
gotten there he hasn't had a chance to
go through a draft yet with them so I'm
hopeful that he's going to get a chance
to build up around him and give him a
fighting chance because it just hasn't
been fair like I look I'm watching the
Superbowl ban and and I'm watching
Garofalo and make some plays and I'm
sitting here going is there anything
Jimmy Garoppolo does that Sam Donald
could do if he had Kyle Shanahan and
that's and that system in place like a
lot of the success for these guys at
that position early on is is dependent
on on where they land and what they have
around them
well imagine Joe burrow with San
Francisco oh gosh
yeah I mean he's got Jill burrow
everybody talked about quarterbacks
wanting to have a you know kind of their
super human trait and with Jill burrow
it's not arm strength what his
superhuman strength is his vision like
his field vision is as good as I've seen
from from any quarterback I've ever done
like his ability to see things to work
through progression and get the ball out
of his hand as as good as I've ever seen
and what Kyle Shanahan's brain matched
with this kids knowledge to be able to
dissect the defense that'd be scary if I
had Kyler Murray Baker Mayfield in this
year's draft what would be the draft
order I would say great question Kyler
Murray is so unique I would say probably
Kyler Murray Jill burrow
then Baker would be my guest but I would
say there's more of a discussion between
the first two I would say Baker would be
third no matter what but there will be
some some teams with certain offenses
that would favor
others would be more insured intrigued
by what you can get with Cuyler Murray
are you in the benchpress area at the
combine
I am fortunately there's a there's
nobody on the bench press at this point
in time but what could you throw up if I
said why don't you get in there and let
me hear I'd buckle buckle I did I did I
did 13 my senior year going at
Appalachian State at 13 reps and then I
can honestly tell you Dan that was in
the year 1999 and I have not gotten
under a bench press since 1999 I'm a
dhama I'm a dumbbell guy but that was
when you were on HGH and that helped you
with the the 225 right eye well you know
no comments but the thing about the
bench press when it gets quiet in here
you hope that they're cheering because
then you hear some you'll hear some
things when that when they're trying to
squeeze out that last rep always it's
not always pretty
- is clay hey have fun out there and
good luck we'll be counting on you I
appreciate it
that's Daniel Jeremiah NFL Network
analyst for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]